hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and i've been
investing in property successfully but
i've also made
many mistakes over the last 12 years and
i in this video i'm going to be
answering your
property investment questions anything
niggly you've got
around tax mortgages rent to rent buy
sellets anything at all
comment your questions below and i'm
going to be answering your questions
next week however right now i'm going to
be answering the questions from the
previous
week please if you enjoy my videos
please do smash the like button that
really means the world to me
also if you're not already subscribed
subscribe and turn the notification bell
on
now while i'm answering the questions
from last week if you have a question
that pops into your mind
write it comment it because i can do
these videos if you actually do put your
questions below so comment like crazy
let me know your niggling questions
because i really believe that the only
reason
you're not where you want to be in
property is because
you're stuck because you don't know the
answer to something and that's why every
single week on a sunday evening at seven
i put myself available to answer your
property investment questions so
last week we had some really interesting
questions and i'm gonna get these up
right now
so george c said let's say i had
250 000 pounds would it be better for me
to invest into
two cheaper houses or one more expensive
house
i would want the house or houses to go
up in value
and which one do you think i could get
the most rent from
so george my advice would probably to
split this into two houses or
buy as many houses as you can and the
reason is is because if you've got 250
000 pounds the average house for 250 000
pounds
is going to give you a rent of probably
around about 1200 pounds
but a house for 125 grand the rent is
only going to be a little bit less maybe
900 pounds
so you're gonna get a much higher return
on investment if you
leverage your money and buy as many
properties as you can however if you've
got 250 grand
and potentially you could buy a lot more
than two houses if you're gonna
use the bank's money and take on
mortgages so my advice would be
to always look to maximize your money
every time you invest a pound
you want to be getting as much as
possible back so i wouldn't go and just
dump them into one house
100 would not burning desire says
if i bought a house for 75 000 pounds
but others now tell me i should have got
it for fifty thousand pounds
and i did spend two and a half thousand
on a refurb is this loss a biggie
since i watch a lot of your videos oh
geez um
my mindset tells me as long as it's
making me money and i keep it in the
long term that's fine
okay so the reason i said oh geez is
because you watch a lot of my videos and
you're asking me if it's a biggie or not
when you bought a house for 75 grand
that you could have bought for 50. and i
would say yes
that is a big egg because i mean listen
there's no point getting upset over
spilt milk so if you've already bought
it and it is making you decent money
it's giving you a good return investment
then
fine but i would definitely learn from
it because if
if you could have bought it for fifth
day firstly i'd make sure that that is
the case it's not just
dave down the pub saying that you want
when you buy a house you want to buy
as cheap as possible and the thing is
this is really what i find really
interesting sometimes when people are
buying houses they just think oh it's
black paper money
100 grand 110 105 doesn't really matter
but
the difference between 100 and 105
that's
five grand imagine if you went to an atm
machine and took out
five grand in hard cash but then
accidentally
left it and left that you'd be
absolutely
devastated because that's five grand
and in the same way when you're buying a
house if you knock five grand off the
price
it's not really any different it's still
money it's still five grand
and the reason i like property so much
is because you can knock property prices
down
it's negotiable so if you're buying gold
or bitcoin or stocks
you can't negotiate the price property
is one of the very few assets where you
can actually choose
between you and the seller what price
you pay it for
and that's why it's so cool because you
can just find motivated sellers so when
you're buying a property always ask them
to name the figure first and always say
if i was to buy cash tomorrow what's the
lowest you could accept
and still live with and then wait for to
hear their figure and then even try and
get them a little bit lower than that so
it's really important to buy as cheap as
you possibly can i hope that helps
thanks for watching my videos
and hey guys you guys if you're enjoying
it smash the like button i really really
appreciate it alex ives not a question
but one of your lampshades is very
slightly
wonky man uh we've actually moved rooms
so like just for you actually alex we've
moved
because of the wonky lampshade i've
moved into a whole new room i hope you
like the setting by the way let me know
in the comments if you like this setting
it's very
green and leafy so let me know if you
enjoy it i'll probably be back in the
usual
wonky pictured room at some point though
very very soon
vicky ferrara says i'm a 65 year old
woman and just bought my first home in
the uk
it's a three bed terraced house but
instead of living in it i decided to
rent it out
good for you i paid cash 140 000 pounds
but now one two more with a hundred
percent equity i have in it
do i just go to a bank and get a
mortgage on it is that what you mean
about refinancing
i won't get any pension here so need to
start making some serious money
and decisions in property i also don't
know what the term rent to rent means
is that what i'd call subletting have
recently subscribed and watch all your
videos
never too late kiwi girl vicky firstly i
just want to say i'm very very honored
that you're watching all the way over
from new
zealand and it's great to have you on
youtube
um so there's quite a few questions in
there so the first thing is
you bought it cash yeah if you refinance
it the definition of refinancing
is getting a mortgage on that which you
could do so you could take a mortgage on
the property that you own outright in
cash
and then when you get that mortgage you
can then invest it heavily into property
um you asked about rent to rent
is that what i call subletting so
subletting is actually illegal because
subletting is when you rent a property
and you have
like an ast contract you you become a
tenant but then
you put other tenants in the property so
it's like you're a tenant but then
you're putting tenants in
normally you're doing that without
proper consent from the landlord so
that's subletting
rent to rent is when you do it legally
and use a management agreement so you
never become a tenant yourself
you take on management agreement on a
property and then you put tenants in it
so you can still make a lot of profit
doing this
but it is not illegal like subletting it
i hope that helps and good luck in your
property journey
if you have a follow-up question by the
way vicky comment and next week i'll do
my best to answer as well
paulina hi samuel we live in a property
with the
right to buy if we buy it we cannot sell
it for the next 10 years
but we can rent it out we'll get a
substantial discount to purchase it
i'm thinking to buy the property because
it's heavily discounted
the mortgage will be low and rent it out
with the profit between rent and
mortgage
i will buy a second property to live in
so after all i'll have two properties
how would you go about it would you go
for a standard mortgage
would i be able to get two mortgages
thank you so much for sharing your
knowledge
so paulina first thing i want to say is
massive congratulations it sounds like
you've got a really good plan
in fact one of my very first student was
called jl her name was jl spooner she
came to the crash course in 2014.
can you believe it and she was living in
a
council flat she was a tenant and
because she'd lived there a long time
she also like you she had the right to
buy it
and she did exactly what you're talking
about she bought the property
at a discount um and then she rented it
out and she's gone on to buy more
property so what you're wanting to do is
absolutely 100 do-able in fact jl
spooner's interview
i'll leave a card or i'll put a link in
the description or both so you can watch
her interview so what you want to do is
absolutely doable
in terms of mortgageability if you're
buying a property to rent out
you're going to want to get a buy to let
mortgage if you're buying it to live in
it you're going to get a residential
mortgage
and of course you can have two mortgages
you can even have two residential
mortgages usually a lot of lenders will
let you do that
if you've got to change circumstances so
you're on the right track keep me posted
how you're getting on and good luck
if hi samuel how do you know if an
estate agent is legitimate
is there any government protection from
fraudulent estate agents
so there's government protection against
fraudulent anything
you you can't be fraudulent and continue
being in business you'll be closed down
you'll be um arrested the courts will
sort you out and if you're fraudulent
the police will sort you out so
i think maybe you're not you don't mean
fraudulent maybe you just mean a little
bit
shady um so in terms of estate agents
uh how do you know if they're legitimate
you asked most estate agents will be
registered with an ombudsman
so i would if you're worried about an
estate agent i mean to be honest
uh i first usually when you're doing
business with an estate agent
they're passing you a property but
they're not charging you a fee
so i don't quite know what your concern
is
i mean how is an estate agent going to
screw you over that's the first thing
whenever you're doing business with
someone you need to always say
what's the best case what's the likely
case what's the worst case
now if the worst case is you're about to
invest your life savings with this
business or with this person
and if it goes wrong you're going to be
financially crippled then sure
you've got to really do your due
diligence you've got to figure out if
they
are legitimate and and and you know
maybe check that they're with the
property ombudsman in in case of an
estate
agent look at reviews and etc etc but
with an estate agent
because you're not actually usually
giving them any money
they're that they're they're selling you
a house and they're charging the seller
i can't really see that they would screw
you over apart from wasting some time so
i'd probably just get that fear out of
your head a little bit um
personally but for sure do research
google them
check there with a property ombudsman um
i hope that helps
okay jithin says will you ever buy a
home to live in for the rest of your
life
um i'm sure at some point me and my
family will buy a home to live in
the thing is it doesn't make financial
sense
if i bought the house that i live in
there'd be
so much cash tied up giving me no return
on investment at all
it would pain me so badly the only way
i'd buy a house to live in
would be if i if i just said you know
what this is not a commercial decision
i love the house i want to be here
forever
you know we've got we've got we've
finished having all the kids we want to
have
and it's in the perfect location and we
just don't want any risk of being
evicted as
tenants maybe then we would buy not in
any rush to buy
quite happy renting just because it
doesn't make commercial sense to do that
hope that helps
help flush samuel the part where you
talked about your car did you buy
outright to get that tax years expense
up to one two six
instead of deducting it over five years
or so
um unfortunately hella flush i don't
think i actually get any
tax deductions really on my car um i
really should have bought a tesla
because tesla's you can run completely
through the business
my car is a range rover um i did buy it
although i didn't buy it outright for
cash
same reason why because if i'd have put
one two six
hundred twenty six thousand pounds and
just put it into a car
again it's that that money's locked up
so my wife who's actually behind the
camera on this occasion
uh she deals with all the personal
finances with the
the rent the car and all that stuff i
deal with the
business finances um so
no i don't think unless you can
enlighten me if i can claim back more
more than i thought with my range rover
then let me know i would i'd love to be
able to do that
and then previously before i bought my
car i actually have leased all my cars
and my wife
leases her car and again it usually
makes financial sense to do this
and there are certain cars as well where
you can lease them and you can put them
through the company
so i i get the same way as would i ever
buy a house to live in similar kind of
question
if i bought a house to live in i would
do it knowing that it's not the best
commercial decision but i just want to
and that's kind of what i did about with
my car i drive my car and i bought my
car because i
really really like it i know it's not
the best financial thing i know i can't
claim it all back on the business
i know it doesn't make sense but i just
really like it so
it's kind of a luxury but i bought it
knowing that knowing that okay this
doesn't make commercial sense to do this
this is not an investment it's a
complete liability
but i just want to do it so don't i
think the
the trick is not to try and trick
yourself and
people try and justify bad financial
decisions and try and pretend it's an
investment or pretend it's
like really or do you just want to do it
so if you're going to buy a liability
at least just accept that it's a bad
investment
but you're doing it purely because you
want to i think that's probably my
general thoughts i hope that helps
what we got next um zaid
let's say you're following the brr
strategy and take out a bridging loan
to cover eighty percent of the cost to
buy a hundred thousand
property on top of the twenty thousand
pound down payment
you will also need funding to refurbish
the property before refinancing
where does this money come from can you
somehow use the bridging loan for this
thanks in advance
zade yes you can there are a lot of
bridging companies that will also give
you development finance so they'll lend
you
to actually do the property up which is
really really cool
prue says i have found a seven bed hmo
for 145 000 pounds at 27
return on investment if it's a good deal
how would i pass it on to an investor
because i'm only
15. oh my goodness well the fact that
you're 15
is just really really cool um i started
out in property when i was 17 so not
massively different in age
so listen if you're finding good deals
and you're 15 years old
firstly i just want to say awesome
you're probably going to struggle
to set up a company and to start selling
your deals to investors because you're a
little bit young
so my advice to you though i'm i'm not
the kind of guy that would just say
you're too young though and i even get
criticized people say
samuel why are you giving 15 you and 16
year old kids advice about property they
should just be focusing on their studies
i'm like listen i run a youtube channel
and i teach
property and i'm going to teach anyone
that asks me i'm not going to say you're
too
young you're too old you're too poor
you're too rich
i don't discriminate against anybody i'm
not going to say you're too stupid
either
you'll never succeed you're like that
would be completely wrong
when i started out in property i was 17
i didn't have pretty much any education
behind me
i failed really in school i had a few
gcses i could people could have easily
said
you're too young and written me off but
in the same way
no people didn't do that to me i had a
lot of people that believed in me and
supported me so that's what i want to do
to other people so
listen 15 respect my advice to you would
be to um
co deal source okay find an a deal
sourcing company and say to them look
you're selling deals to investors
can i bring you deals and if they're
good you can sell my deals and i want to
i want a kickback referral fee that
would be my advice to you
but just congratulations for even
watching these videos really really cool
tyrone saxton the government are
printing
and paying out all this money eg through
furlough
giving out loans and grants how on earth
do you think the government are planning
to recoup all this money back
do you think they'll raise taxes next
year i want to hear your prediction
tyrone i don't think they're going to
raise taxes no
i mean they might raise taxes a little
bit but i don't think that's how they're
going to get this money back i mean as
you rightly said they're printing out
money so
it's hardly really that generous it's
like if i gave you money
if i was like hey here's here's a
thousand pounds you'd say oh thank you
so much but if i had the ability to
print money
and i just printed a thousand and then
gave it to you you might not be quite so
grateful so
whilst i'm not saying we shouldn't be
grateful for the government support
um my slightly cynical brain
and i don't mean to turn this into a
conspiracy show or anything like that
but i
think that the reason the government are
giving out furlough and giving out so
much bounce back loans
is partly because they want to help the
economy yes but i also think the
government very much like people to rely
on them
so what's going to happen is everyone's
going to become really dependent on the
government because they're going to owe
the government all this money
and when people ask the same reasons why
country will lend another country money
it's not because they're trying to help
the country out
they'll they'll oh you really need money
you're earning money oh here's some
money and they'll lend them
a few billion and the country will be
great and then they'll swallow up into a
black hole
and it's the same as a lot of these
bounce back loans and and furlough and
stuff and i mean furlough to be fair we
don't have to pay back but bounce back
loans we do
so all that's gonna happen is most
people that gets back get bounce back
loans
will just end up just spending it and it
will disappear and it will go down the
black hole which is kind of
default not the fault but a result of
the restrictions that the government put
in place in the first place so the
government say you can't do business you
can't trade you have to close down
you can't open shops you have to social
distance you can't run events you can't
do this you can't do that
and everyone's like oh man strangled
financially and they go but don't worry
you can have a bounce back loan here you
go but you have to pay me back
so in the same way that when a country
gives another country money that country
now becomes a slave really to that
country
so this country can call the loan back
in has power over it
and the government i've always said this
that what the government want is they
want complete
control over you and i and what i teach
is i teach
financial independence and
i think it's a real shame uh i think the
rich are going to get richer the poor
are going to get poorer
and i know it's bad news and the way the
way to
the the way to fight against this is to
become financially
literate and also to become financially
independent so that you don't have to
rely on the government
but yeah i think it's going to get
really really rough
doly says i am from israel and i want to
invest in london
soon i wanted to ask i am going to buy a
house in london and rent it out as a hmo
i wanted to ask if i will always have
tenants if it is a good area
and if hmo works all year another
question
is there any months that are less
successful and then my annual average
income goes down
so so basically uh
dolly no i mean with hmo properties
especially in london you're probably
going to find this
full all year round if it's a
professional hmo property
there's no particular peak or i mean
i've found that
it's pretty it's pretty steady so
service to accommodation is very
different service accommodation you're
going to have quite much you have busy
months
with hmos no and you're going to find
they've rent very well as well in london
now london is expensive i assume you
know how much it is to buy in london but
the rents are also expensive
you're not going to get the best return
on investment in london but
yeah you're going to have no problem
renting out hmos in london generally
speaking
make sure you speak to a hmo management
company before you buy
and you've got that in place as well so
good luck and if there's any way i can
be of any more
further help let me know okay sigran
how do you raise finance and find joint
ventures
partners for development uh
great question so how do you find joint
ventures afford development and raise
funds for development
so the development has to be good you
can be the best
person at raising finance but if you've
got a really crappy deal
and there's not much profit to be made
in there you're probably going to
struggle to get an investor to come in
and
come in with you because what investors
look for is
they're looking to make money so they
want to come in they want it to be all
easy
usually they want it to be all
systemized they want to put their money
into something that's
going to make money where the research
has been done the gross development
value is done
there's not that much risk so the first
thing is to have really good deals
the second thing is to tell people about
your deal you've got to make it known
um put yourself out there so and the
third thing is to know how to
how to how to ask for money to to be
able to
um understand the right language to use
um
so there's quite a lot to it but i think
the very first thing is
get good deals that'd be my biggest
advice
james watson samuel when refinancing
do you go back to the original mortgage
provider for the revaluation or go to a
new provider as obviously there is
erc to consider and that has an impact
on both your roi
and yield um so you're going to have to
pay erc
early repair repayment charge if if
you're going to get charged by
your mortgage lender because you're
trying to refinance too soon
you're going to get charged whether you
refinance with anybody else or whether
you try and refinance with them
it's a fixed term so it might worth
speaking to them for sure
um i would always when i'm refinancing
though i don't go to one lender i just
read
i just speak to an independent broker
and let them look across the board so i
think that's probably the best thing to
do
because they've got access to all the
different lenders and they'll be able to
give you the best rate
so i hope that helps uh steve brandon
hi samuel how do i release equity from a
similar question from a mortgage i've
had for
only a month all right so okay
if you've only had the mortgage for a
month chances are you're probably going
to be fixed
normally when you take out a mortgage
they'll fix it for a certain amount of
time it might be six months it might be
two years
and if you try and refinance and pull
equity out
before you've let that end you're going
to be charged a fee
now you might just want to swallow the
fee and say you know what i've got a lot
of equity in this
all right there's two thousand pound fee
which is early uh repayment charge
whatever i'll take that because i know
that when i get this money that from
this equity i'm about to invest it and
make a load of money another option
would be if you've got
a mortgage a small mortgage and you've
got equity in the property
you could potentially look at getting
another lender that's going to come on
and give you a second charge so
a mortgage will always want a first
charge on your property so let's say you
own a property and it's worth two
hundred thousand pounds
and you've got a mortgage for a hundred
thousand pounds on it
and you've got a hundred thousand equity
you're never going to be able to
get any lender that's going to give you
a hundred thousand pounds because
that would mean that that would mean
that you're not leaving any money in the
deal yourself at all
so normally 75 loan to value is about
normal so 200 000 pound house
you might be able to get 150 000 pound
equity i hope this is making sense and
you're following if not
rewind watch again or comment and ask
more questions
so a mortgage lender will always want a
first charge so if they've got a hundred
thousand pounds
uh that they've given you you've got a
mortgage of a hundred thousand mad
the property is two hundred thousand
pounds if you can't
refinance because you've got fixed um
you've got a fixed mortgage length then
what you could do is you could just say
well actually i'm going to get a second
lender to come and give me 50 000 pounds
and they'll have a second charge on the
property so that's another option that
you can do
i don't want to get too technical on
this because i'm not a mortgage advisor
but i can only speak from experience
and this is something that i've done
many many many times
okay naomi says hey hope you're well
love your videos thank you so much would
you start a rent to rent through a
limited company or sole trader i have a
95 if small
if if some trader would
when would you make the switch so i
would start with a limited company now i
mean the reason is is
it's going to protect you because if
you've got a limited company
then the company is going to ring fence
you the individual so
should something go wrong let's say
you've got a rent to rent business and
someone slips in the property or
anything happens
then they're not going to sue you
personally they're going to sue the
company
which gives you some sort of protection
also there's a lot of tax advantages to
running any business through a limited
company um so i would always recommend
doing it through a limited company hope
that helps
michael bennett i'm the future
could you make you're the future hi mate
i'm the i think that maybe i should say
in the future in the future
could you maybe do some videos investing
in property abroad for example france
spain italy etc will be interesting to
see if the same principles can work for
holiday homes
uh michael you're in luck actually
because um just on wednesday
i did a whole interview with a guy who
came on my
crash course he came on the property
investors crash course he bought four
sorry five houses in stoke on trent and
then he thought hmm
maybe i could do this in italy and he
went on to do the same thing in italy
bought another five houses in italy
and he says that he's making better
returns in italy then he is in stoke on
trent
using the exact same formula that he
learned from me so it's very very very
similar
i recommend you check that interview out
i'll leave a little card and i'll also
leave it in the description
for you to watch so hope that helps and
good luck on all your investments
okay user says i have three thousand
pounds saved what would be the best
thing
to go far in property to start on 18.
okay so if you're 18 you've got 3000
pounds i mean listen you
can't do a lot with 3000 pounds but you
can
you can start with nothing so it all
depends how creative you are
you could potentially get a rent to rent
with as little as 3 000 pounds
i would be inclined to put at least
some of that towards your education
because if you've only got three
thousand pounds you're not gonna be able
to go and buy a property
uh normally speaking you're gonna need
to be very very creative
so you you need to learn and become
knowledgeable on how to be creative so
i definitely put something towards
education um
and and map out a business plan of
exactly what you want to do
surrender hi sam you'll love your videos
when buying a property via bridging loan
i understand it's a cash payment
however to an estate agent is it still
considered borrowing against
the property or considered a cash
purchase so if i'm buying a property and
i'm going to be using bridging finance
i'll tell the estate agent that it's
just a cash
buy because it's not a mortgage i guess
i guess everything in one sense is a
cash buyer because even if you get a
mortgage you're still buying it cash but
you're just getting the cash from the
mortgage so
it's kind of a little bit normally the
real i'd say something the real reason
an estate agent wants to know if you're
buying cash or mortgage
is because if you buy a mortgage they
want to sell you their mortgage products
whereas if you're buying cash
and you're using bridging it's it's
effectively the same as just buying it
cash
so uh because a short-term loan you'll
get it buy the property and then you'll
refinance down the line usually so
i just say cash hope that helps all
right last one
jacob claire hi samuel my question is
that i'm planning to go to university
and to go into property what university
courses would you recommend
i understand that i don't need to go but
it's a personal preference
um listen
don't go to university because you want
to go to university
okay don't go to university because you
think it's nice because your parents
want you to because you think oh i may
as well
everybody else's it'll be fun i'll learn
a thing or two
it's a bad way to learn about life
skills
only go to university if and this is
just my opinion
if it fits with your long-term plan so
if you're saying
samuel i want to go into property long
term my goal is to be a property
investor and to be making loads of money
as a real estate
king all right fine don't go to
university then because
even if you go on a real estate course
yeah you'll get a
certificate at the end of the course and
a credit an accreditation and all that
and a hat and a little scroll but guess
what that ain't gonna help you
it's not gonna help you in any way apart
from you being able to say oh look i've
got a
uh i've got a degree it doesn't help
so i mean geez i only go to university
if you'll
plan long term if you want to be a
doctor that's your end goal and you're
like okay how am i going to get there
well i need to go to uni as part of the
plan then fine if it fits
but don't go to university if it doesn't
fit with your long-term plan that's my
advice
i never went to university so if you
want to learn about property
it's much better to either get a job in
property
or go on some training even if it's free
and i'm not trying to sell my courses
here but like
my cousin max max was about to go to
university to study real estate and
property
i told him you're a dummy don't do it
what's your purpose oh i want to learn
about prophecy i was like mate
he ended up coming doing some training
with me and getting a job
with me in property and within about
three or four months
he knew more than all his other friends
because this was years ago now that have
now
graduated from uni about property it's
just
and the guys that teach you at
university okay
the lecturers they're teaching business
or if they're teaching
property most of them aren't making good
money in property anyway so you need to
learn from people that you actually want
to be like so that's my advice
own speaking from experience i'd love to
know your thoughts though folks so
comment your thoughts below
comment your questions below and again
if you enjoy my video please do smash
the like button you've got to subscribe
as well because if you don't subscribe
you won't even be notified next week
when i answer your questions so comment
below
subscribe turn the notification bell on
and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
foreign